speaking of which
if we could uh talk about gpt3
a little bit i think it's an interesting
thought-provoking set of ideas that
openai is pushing forward i think it's
good for us to talk about
the limits and the possibilities in your
network so
in general what are your thoughts about
this recently released
very large 175 billion parameter
language model
so i have i haven't uh directly
evaluated it yet from what i have seen
on twitter and
you know other people evaluating it it
looks very intriguing you know i am i am
very intrigued by some of the properties
it is displaying and
and of course the text generation uh
part of
that was already evident in gpt2
you know that it can generate cochrane
text over uh
long distances that was uh but of course
the weaknesses are also pretty visible
in saying that okay it is not
really carrying a world state around um
and
you know sometimes you get sentences
like i went
up the hill to reach the valley or the
thing now there are some
you know completely incompatible
statements or
when you're traveling from one place to
the other it doesn't take into account
the time of travel
things like that so those things i think
will happen less than gpt
3 because it is trained on even more
data and
so and it has it can do even more longer
distance
uh uh coherence um but it will still
have the fundamental limitations that it
doesn't have a world model
uh and it can't run simulations in its
head to
find whether something is true in the
world or not
do you think within so it's taking a
huge amount of text from the internet
and forming a compressed representation
do you think
in that could could emerge something
that's an approximation of
of a world model which essentially could
be used for reasoning
and it's a it's a it's a so i'm not
talking about gpt three i'm talking
about gpt four or five and gpt 10.
yeah i mean they will look more
impressive than gpg3
so you can if you take that to the
extreme then uh
a markov chain of just first order and
if you if you
uh go to um i'm taking the other extreme
if you read shannon's
book right uh he has a model of english
text
which is based on faster markov chains
second order markov chains third markov
chain sensing that
okay the markov chains look better than
uh
faster markov chains right so does that
mean a faster markov chain has a model
of the world yes it does uh
so yes in that level uh when you go
higher order models or more uh
sophisticated structure in the model
like the transformer networks have
yes they have a model of the text world
um but that is not a model of
uh the world it's it's a model of the
text world and it will have in
interesting uh properties and it will be
useful
but just scaling it up is not going to
give us a gi or natural language
understanding or meaning
the question is whether
being forced to compress a very large
amount of text
yeah forces you to construct things that
are
very much like because the ideas of
concepts and meaning
is a spectrum yeah
so in order to form that kind of
compression
maybe it will be forced to
figure out abstractions which
look awfully a lot like the kind of
things that we think about
as uh as concepts as world models as
common sense
is that possible no i don't think it is
possible because the information is not
there
well the information is uh is there
behind the text
right now unless somebody has written on
all the details
about how everything works in the world
to the
the absurd amounts like okay it is
easier to walk forward than backward
uh that you have to open the door to go
out of the thing uh
doctors wear underwear you know unless
all these things somebody has written
down somewhere or you know
somehow the program found it to be
useful for compression from some other
text
uh the information is not there so
that's an argument that like
text is a lot lower fidelity than the
you know the experience of our physical
world like right
so you can taste a thousand words like
that kind of thing
well in this case pictures aren't really
so the
the richest aspect of the physical world
isn't even just pictures it's the uh
it's the interactivity of the world yeah
it's
being able to um yeah
interact it's almost like
it's almost like if you could interact
so i
i i disagree well maybe i agree with you
that picture's worth a thousand words
but
a thousand it's still yeah you could say
you could capture it with the gpt
x so i wonder if there's some
interactive element where
a system could live in text world where
it could um be part of the chat
be part of you know talking to people
it's it's interesting i mean
fundamentally so
you're making a statement about the
limitation of text
i okay let's so let's say we have a
text corpus that includes basically
every experience we could possibly have
i mean just a very large corpus of text
and also interactive components i guess
the question is whether the neural
network architecture these
very simple transformers but if they had
like hundreds of
trillions or whatever comes after a
trillion
parameters whether that could store
the information needed that's
architecturally do you have
like do you have thoughts about the
limitation on that side of
things with neural networks i mean so
transformer is
you know still a feed forward neural
network this uh uh it's it has a
very uh interesting architecture which
is good for uh text modeling and
probably some aspects of
uh video modeling but it is still a feed
forward architecture and
you believe in the the feedback
mechanism the recursion oh
and and also because you know causality
you know being able to do counterfactual
reasoning
being able to do you know intervention
so which is uh uh
um actions in the world uh so all those
things
uh require different kinds of models to
be built
uh i i don't think uh transformers uh
captures that uh family it is very good
at statistical modeling
of text and and it will become better
and better with more data
uh bigger models but that is
only going to get so far you know
finally when you in so i had this joke
on
uh twitter saying that hey this is a
model that has read all of quantum
mechanics
and theory of relativity and we are
asking it to do text completion or
you know we are asking you to solve
simple puzzles that you know
when when you have agi if you if you you
know that's not what you ask a system to
do if you just
you know we ask we'll ask the system to
do experiments you know what should
uh and uh and come up with hypothesis
and uh you know revise the hypothesis
based on evidence from experiments all
those things right
those are the things that we want the
system to do when we have a gi
not solved with simple puzzles
you